ich bin heute auf den weg nach berlin um
multitalent julia malik bei sich zu
hause zu besuchen
[Musik]
sie ist schauspieler musikerin
ich bin begeistert von ihrem stil und
wollte schon immer mal wissen wie wohnt
sie eigentlich
[Musik]
das muss es doch sein
ja und ich sehe dass wir sind doch noch
einen schönen dazu ganz gespannt
ja schön hast du es hier jetzt sind wir
endlich mal bei dir jetzt mussten unsere
tipps zeigen
[Musik]
jeder ecke ist irgendwie war es total
schön egal bisschen glamour des ökolöwen
mozzarella wir haben so ein
italienisches flair nicht wohin mit mir
da ganz großartig ist richtig richtig
lecker aber meine liebe julia eigentlich
bin ich ja hier zur wohnungsbesichtigung
maximal deine wohnung zeigen musst du
dich mit ins bett nehmen halte wollte
dass mein lieblingsort sehen und er ist
tatsächlich liga und ist wirklich mein
absoluter größter luxus in der letzten
zeit durch ein eigenes zimmer habe ich
gestehe ich habe zwei große laster des
umkleide und sicher wie man sehen kann
und du schreibst ja auch gerade und die
schreib ab 1 ich bin gerade beim
überarbeiten der ersten fassung
es geht um eine mutter die durchdreht
okay du bist ja sehen gleich wenn wir
durch die wohnung gehen es gibt sehr
viele orte wenn du dich mit einem wort
verewigen müsstest was wäre das
[Musik]
und jetzt juli am alex persönlichkeit in
drei wörtern
ok also eigentlich was jemand anders
über mich sagen der würde dann sagen sie
ist wahnsinnig krug und ganz schön und
kann es ihr fällt dem auf was lustiges 1
ich glaube ich bin wahnsinnig neugierig
ich glaube sehr leidenschaftlich und
sehr interessiert an vorgängen und was
so alles passiert
[Musik]
wieso lebst du eigentlich überlegen ich
bin zu ihm geboren und bin dann aber
relativ früh schon weggezogen meinen
eltern und wissen sehr viel emotion in
deutschland und dann hatte ich
irgendwann immer die sehnsucht mal nach
hause zu kommen
das heißt man so ganz nah am himmel ist
das wirklich an dieser wohnung
tatsächlich sehe also dieses zuhause
bedeutet tatsächlich sehr viel weil ich
dich liebe zu pflanzen
die ruhe und meine bestimmte arten von
möbeln und bildern jetzt zeigt uns doch
mal deine 3 lieblingsstücke
die fahren doch wahnsinnig schön naja
diese frau ist so toll es gab auch mann
mit schnurrbart den wollte ich auch
andere weit es geht nicht dass besonders
sein finde ich muss was eigenes sagen
das ist ja die ist ganz toll ist dass
nämlich ein kamerastativ ein altes zum
beruf und es ist ja immer diese
vorbildung die man so heißt das ist
natürlich aus büchern wie das
beschrieben ist oder aus denen aus
bildern die man gesehen hat so setzt
sich das dann glaube ich zusammen
ich blieb das wahnsinnig diese alten
möbel die sonne bestimmte substanz haben
also ich bin tatsächlich sehr glücklich
wenn ich arbeiten kann
dann war ich sehr froh dass ich
irgendwann diesen alten tatsächlich
teams schreibtisch gefunden habe der so
möglich ist und so dem fühlt man sich
auch ein bisschen mächtiger du machst du
auch gerne yoga oder ja ich mache das
jeden tag eine halbe stunde
[Musik]
wann spielst du geige seit ich sechs bin
seit elf jahren mit dieser band hands up
excitement
[Musik]
richtig richtig schön also jetzt
versuche das tier dafür
die verlogenen werden dann möchte
draußen in der madryn das möchte man
eben ab raus zu sein und hier ist mein
absoluter außenseiter trotzdem ins leben
zu rufen
wir brauchen ja von mozart
hat sich sagen lösen sich eine wunde
wunderschöne wohnung und ganz okay ist
kann ich noch ein bisschen geld passt
etwas nicht gleich kleine skript
arbeiten 6
[Musik]